and in baltimore one of the things
they're working on in the laboratory is
using
lamar jackson in a way that he rarely if
ever has been used before at the nfl
level under center greg roman the
offensive coordinator the team who's
been embattled based upon his failure to
fully develop a robust passing game
he admitted yesterday in a conference
call with season ticket holders that
under center is going to be part of what
they do percentage of which i cannot
state at this point i don't know the
extent of it we're working on it and
evaluating it every day it's something
we certainly will use from time to time
some games more than others i believe
it's a very important part in the
development of a quarterback
going forward so look great fine why
haven't they done it in the first three
years of his career then chris
that's a good question you know hey the
nfl has gone into this shotgun phase i
think they're probably looking at it
like hey he's a great athlete let's get
him space let's get him away from the
line of scrimmage i really perked up
when i heard this yesterday the ravens
don't need a lot on offense to like
yeah
to to change our minds i mean we already
know it's a really damn good offense
we're probably a little critical of them
at times but yeah we want to see the
passing game be able to carry them
there's no doubt i think this is this is
a sneaky way to do it a little sub no
subtle change there subtle sorry subtle
change all right and
um not not like a huge drastic like oh
we got to reinvent the offense yeah zip
it up but we could still run our offense
and create some different advantages
with the quarterback under center first
off bootlegs are you still laughing at
subtle okay okay no that's fine but i'm
trying to be subtle thank you but
bootlegs are
like are going to be a different
different ball game now when you're
underneath the center you know we've
talked about this in the past when
you're in the shotgun those linebackers
that safety says in the box there's a
little bit easier oh i can see the
quarterback and they're running back and
he's riding them and yes but the
picture's clearer now think about whoa
lamar jackson's turned his back and i
don't know if he gave the ball and i'm
and he's not far from the line of
scrimmage so i'm trying to see through
offensive linemen and defense alignment
wait did he have it did he give it you
know to uh the running back from ohio
state no oh no he's over there he ran
the bootleg uh oh he threw it his guy's
wide open or he turned the corner and
ran for 50 yards
that's where i like it also with the
just a straight play action pass the
same element i mean come on mike other
than the chiefs every great offense we
talk about in football kicks ass in the
play action to pass department right now
in the nfl sorry for my language
liverpool but that's that's really you
know that's where i i perked up when i
heard that i went oh i like that that's
going to give some teams a few more
issues of handling this running game and
lamar jackson
but when it comes to the play-action
pass yeah i remember hearing ron
jaworski explain this 10 15 years ago
and it stuck with me the difficulty for
the quarterback of executing a play
action pass because you're under center
sure you sell the handoff and to sell it
you got to completely turn your back
right defense right
and and after you have pretended to hand
off and turn back sure there's a
different world on the other side of the
line
maybe one defensive end has sprung
through maybe there's a guy who's coming
up in the middle and he's about to get
you maybe there's a guy that you thought
was going to be open and he's got a
safety that is lurking and if you throw
it it's going to get picked off you've
got to completely reorient yourself you
do that's a perspective lamar jackson's
never had chris is that going to be a
challenge for him and how much of a
challenge is it for any quarterback to
see the defense
turn away yeah turn back right oh where
is everybody now yeah no they're they're
definitely a challenge and it's
definitely something you got to rep and
get used to and those things and yes
when you come out of that play action
fake your points are real you got to
turn around kind of reassess wait did
things stay the same or they totally
changed what is it exactly but i think
ultimately that risk
is outweighed by the greater rewards of
wait we we faked the ball and now oh
that you know yeah you turned your back
for a second but hollywood brown
screaming down the middle for a 70-yard
post because that safety came up and got
involved in the running attack or
something like that i just think there's
more ways to be explosive on the
offensive side of the ball and teams
have gotten so good and creative with
the play action passes that they've made
it so simple for the quarterbacks to
where it's a little different than the
ron jaworski age and here i'm just going
to give you a little like exercise here
just right off the bat
like you look at the top 10 offenses in
football from last year hey we know the
chiefs and the bills let's say they were
they were one in three they didn't
really use the play action underneath
the center they have freaky quarterbacks
who just they want to give them the
shotgun and let them do their thing but
the titans at two the vikings at four
the packers at five the buccaneers at
seven the raiders at eight
you know and i would even argue the
colts at 10 were all heavy play action
pass type football teams and 11 and 12
you had the rams and the saints who were
also heavy play action so it's the best
way to create explosive plays and
especially with some of these young
linebackers that are coming in the nfl
micah we've talked about before where
it's spread it's college football
they're not used to pulling guard full
back running oh wait i gotta get down
there this is crazy i gotta make that
tackle what there goes hollywood brown
on a slant route behind me that's where
i think the real great advantage is and
that's why i think you're seeing more
and more teams do it
yeah and look it helps to have a great
running team in order to pull it off you
start getting a defense on its heels
exactly and just for that split second
of uncertainty that's what it's all
about it's about injecting uncertainty
into the defender who gets caught
flat-footed thinking all right oh oh
it's a run
oh crap and there goes the guy who's not
going to catch the long touchdown pass
whether it's hollywood brown rashad
bateman or whoever
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports